we've got breaking news from the
merseyside police um that's relating to
the death of olivia pratt corbell
merseyside police say that detectives
have arrested two men in relation to the
murder of the nine-year-old with one
suspect arrested on suspicion of murder
they were arrested in the runcorn area
in the early hours of this morning a 34
year old man from liverpool has been
arrested on suspicion of murder and
attempted murder he is in police custody
where he's being questioned by
detectives a 41 year old man from nosley
has been arrested on suspicion of
assisting an offender and he is also in
custody um detective chief
superintendent and head of
investigations mark comey has said i
continue to urge anyone who has
information that can help our
investigation into olivia's tragic
murder to please come forward so we can
bring those responsible to justice a
number of people have been arrested in
respect of this investigation however we
still need the public's help in ensuring
that we can build a strong evidential
picture so justice is served for olivia
and her family with this i appeal for
those who
may have information no matter how small
that could continue to help our
inquiries to contact us directly or
anonymously and we will do the rest
that's from detective chief
superintendent and head of
investigations mark comey so to
reiterate merseyside police say two men
have been arrested in relation to the
murder of nine-year-old olivia pratt
corbell in duffcoat with one suspect
arrested on suspicion of murder they
were arrested in the early hours of this
morning in the runcorn area a 34 year
old man from liverpool he's been
arrested on suspicion of murder and
attempted murder he's in police custody
he's being questioned by detectives and
a 41 year old man from noseley has been
arrested on suspicion of assisting an
offender and is also in custody so that
is the latest from merseyside police